confusion depending where you come from
for british holiday makers there
yeah very much so if you're heading back
to wales you'll be forced to
quarantine um and those travelers
haven't been given any option
to get out not even a day or two's grace
the restrictions come into force at 4 00
am
tomorrow morning so effectively anyone
on holiday here today who's heading back
to wales knows
that they will have to self quarantine
and that obviously is going to be a
great
frustration but england decided
otherwise which i guess has come as a
bit of a surprise to people considering
that
very many more uh tourists come to
portugal from england
uh than they uh do wales um the
uk government which makes the decisions
for england
has decided that for the moment uh
portugal can stay on the safe
uh travel list now you might imagine um
that
those who who are here who are returning
to england will be breathing
a sigh of relief certainly many of them
that we spoke to on the beach were but
there are still
some people who are very very unhappy
because the fear
that quarantine was going to come in and
that was very much
the expectation during the course of the
week and prompted
many people many tourists to head back
to england early many of them we spoke
to
had paid an absolute fortune to get on
planes you know the seats on planes
were very hard to get and families were
split up we spoke to
several families today where dad and the
sons went home and the mom and the
daughter
are here we spoke to another gentleman
whose
brother had gone back early because he
couldn't miss work on monday
and his wife and his son actually didn't
travel out today
because they feared quarantine was going
to come into place and you can only
imagine now
how people who rushed back to england or
have booked their tickets say for
uh tomorrow to preempt any quarantine
are going to be feeling
because there is no quarantine that's
going to be put in place so i think
there will be a great deal of
frustration and i think
a lot of people will be asking how
different governments can come to
such different conclusions what is it
that
force the welsh government into saying
there needs to be a quarantine relation
to portugal but didn't make the uh the
uk government for england
follow suit uh yeah as i say frustration
but i imagine some people
who are heading back to wales or are
back in wales
will be feeling relieved that they got
out before the quarantine